my name is crystal avoir and I am a
junior here at Hillsdale from Spokane
Washington studying psychology and
German it is my pleasure today to
introduce to you today's speaker John
Marini dr. John Marini is a professor of
political science at the University of
Nevada Reno a former visiting
distinguished fellow at Hillsdale Allen
peak Kirby jr. Center for Constitutional
studies and citizenship in Washington DC
dr. Marini earned his BA at San Jose
State University and his PhD in
government at the Claremont Graduate
School he serves on the board of
directors at the Claremont Institute
which awarded him his Henry Salvatori
prize and the American founding in 2011
dr. Marini served in the Reagan
administration as a special assistant to
Justice Clarence Thomas who was then
chairman of the Equal Employment
Opportunity Commission he is the author
of numerous popular and scholarly
articles in politics political theory
and film especially the films of John
Ford
he is the author or editor of several
books including the Imperial Congress
crisis and the separation of powers and
the political budget Kahn control
Congress the presidency and the growth
of the administration's state please
join me in welcoming mr. dr. John Marini
[Applause]
well thank you Krista for the
introduction thank all of you for coming
on a nice day like this I thought many
of you'd be out golfing or something but
it Hillsdale is a special place it's
always a privilege to come here and I I
was just thinking about the first time I
came here which was about 30 years ago
when I gave a talk on the scandal of
that day this is the end of the Reagan
administration I gave us a talk on the
iran-contra affair
so the scandals haven't disappeared I
mean seems like they've been raised to a
higher art form in Washington in the
last 30 years but it's a real pleasure
to be here
what is interesting about this view of
scandals in this conference is we heard
some very different interpretations of
those famous scandals in American
history that have been treated in the
history books and in the popular culture
as fully understood and fairly resolved
whether they have been fully and
factually let alone truthfully
understood is another question if you
heard Jeff Shepards talk last night you
know that there was much about Watergate
we never knew at the time perhaps what
we know about the infamous scandals of
the past is not determined by what
actually happened but the way in which
the most influential intellectual and
political elites have come to
accommodate and explain what they
themselves have created as a crisis of
the political order insa is such scandal
meant to expose corruption or is it
meant to derail and obscure a new
political reality that appears to be
beyond their control if so perhaps they
do so in order to elevate scandal an
attempt to define its political meaning
for the purpose of preserving the old
order the difficulty of it
interpreting any complex historical
event present or past is not a new one
that's this dilemma was revealed very
well fictionally by the editor of a
newspaper in the great western movie the
man who shot Liberty valance faced with
the necessity of deciding whether to
publish the truth of an explosive
political story the editor justified his
refusal to do so by insisting and I
quote when the legend becomes fact print
the legend I'm afraid we are the
beneficiaries of many printed and
celluloid legends when it comes to the
interpretation of great political events
especially scandals that is because the
events that give rise to scandal are
complicated by the political
bureaucratic economic and social
interests of those whose motives are
rarely revealed consequently scandal
becomes a viable option for those
partisans who think they will be at a
disadvantage in a new and unknown
political environment that may be beyond
their control rather than revealing
truth or exposing corruption most great
scandals arise as a means of obscuring
the political right reality that has
grown out of irreconcilable political or
policy differences the greatest
likelihood of serious scandal arises in
the aftermath of a critical or
transformative election such elections
attempt to alter the political landscape
by attempting to create a new political
consensus that renders the policy-making
authority of the old order obsolete the
defenders of the old order are not above
using any means including scandal to
undermine the illegal Authority of civic
off of the Civic officeholder and dilute
the moral authority of the electorate as
well it is not accidental therefore that
nearly every political saint
scandal sooner or later it's transformed
into a legal drama if then becomes one
that can be and is meant to be
understood and purely personal or non
partisan legal terms it is an attempt to
subordinate politics to law and
partisanship to the neutrality of the
non political institutions although it
is deliberately fought out in the public
stage and it may affect policies in a
decisive manner the legal focus and the
decision-making process is placed in the
hands of bureaucracies and courts it's
taken out of the hands of the electorate
consequently
a partisan victory can be obtained by
successful prosecution of apparently
corrupt office holders it can be and is
justified politically and morally as
upholding the rule of law presupposes
the absolute incorruptibility
of the permanent government although it
provides clarity in terms of simplifying
the issues in a manner suitable for
presentation to a mass public it
obscures the deeper more fundamental
problems that give rise to the perceived
necessity of political scandal nearly
every political administration every
presidential administration has
potential scandal that lies just below
the surface of public life they rarely
erupt into full-blown crisis of the
political order what provides the
occasion for those few scandals that
become political earthquakes in simple
terms you could say that political
scandal can always arise because of the
ongoing necessity of exposing scoundrels
in the political world they are always
those there are always those in
government who seek to private profit
privately from public service and also
there are those who attempt or a thought
to undermine the legitimacy of
government by abusing their power
clearly nearly
all governments in all times provide the
occasion for scoundrels of both kinds
but political scout political scandal
although an ever-present possibility in
government is expecially important in
government in which public opinion often
determines what can or cannot be done
politically scandal can be used to
establish the legitimacy of the
opposition or D legitimize those who
hold elective office in the government
however it is almost always a tool that
remains in the hands of the so called
neutral or nonpartisan permanent non
partisan apparatus of the permanent
government it that means it is primarily
within the domain controlled by the
bureaucracy or the courts of law legal
tactics consist succeed if those
non-partisans institutions are thought
to be beyond reproach
they must retain public confidence in
their partisan neutrality that all
partisans will be treated equally ensure
the permanent government must be thought
to be incorruptible and above politics
but I think as we've seen in these past
days it's difficult to deny that any of
the great scandals in American history
can be understood as above politics
trying to understand this dilemma the
interesting question is why the
potential for serious scandal results in
a political firestorm only when there
are significant moral or political moral
and political or policy differences that
cannot be resolved in a political leak
or a constitutional matter manner really
perhaps we can say following Klauss
events that scandal like war provides
the occasion for politics by other means
the goal of those who rely on skander
scandal to deter defeat their political
and institutional opponents is too
obscure from public consideration the
policy differences
that have become irreconcilable within
the political structure moreover it is
tacit admission that those who use
scandal no longer believe they have the
ability politically to influence future
policymaking when the political climate
is no longer hospitable to the
preservation of their public and private
interests they can turn to those
so-called nonpartisan or neutral
elements of the permanent government
itself then the bureaucracy and courts
can be used to focus the focus the issue
in such a way as to mobilize an
influence public opinion on behalf of a
political agenda that remains hidden in
a constitutional regime where political
Authority establishes the legal
authority of the non political branches
it is the public alone that determines
who will hold office then exercise
political authority in undermining the
political authority in undermining that
political authority authority of the
people in elections scandal is one way
in which the bureaucracy courts and
weaker partisans can triumph in the
political arena even in the face of an
overwhelming political victory in the
electoral arena the political fate of
Richard Nixon revealed the manner in
which modern political scandal would
come to be used for partisan purposes it
provided the model for all subsequent
use of political scandal Nixon won an
election an electoral victory of
monumental proportions in 1972 yet he
was removed from office within the
following year or so
despite the spectacle of Watergate and
the mobilization of political passion
against Nixon there was very little real
political or partisan activity in
defense of Nixon how is it possible to
mobilize political support within the
party or the electorate for a trial that
is in the secret hands of prosecutors
and juries and judges in 1974 we never
had any indication that those
institutions could be corrupt as well if
Geoff Shepard is right they were Nixon
of course being political believed he
had partisan enemies trying to destroy
him but even his Republican supporters
in Congress came to accept Watergate
primarily in legal terms the most famous
line of a Nixon defender Senator Howard
Baker was what did the president know
and when did he know it in such
circumstances that Nixon was forced to
make a legal defense of his office what
was surprising then and now is how
little disagreement there was concerning
the political we a meaning of Watergate
it was and remains the political scandal
by which all scandal is measured it was
a crisis that undermined the political
authority of the president well at the
same time increasing the administrative
authority of the of the executive branch
not surprisingly the intellectual elites
of both parties liberals and
conservatives had come to agree that
Richard Nixon was the problem his
removal was meant to bring about the
solution to a crisis of democratic
government posed by the executive abuse
of power they succeeded in in removing
Nixon they also insisted in empowering
Congress and the bureaucracy the
personal and legal details of Watergate
has cover-up are well known in the
popular culture some of these things are
still being discovered as we noticed
last night but what were the political
consequences of Watergate the political
fortunes of Congress and the presidency
were dramatically reversed as the
editors of the Congressional quarterly
noted in their review the 93rd Congress
which I'll read
quote when the 93rd Congress first
convened in January 1973 after this
great electoral victory of Nixon
President Nixon sweeping assertions of
executive authority Authority posed a
threat to the viability of the
legislative branch that was that
perceived by the legislature remember
it's in the hands of Democrats all of
the legislation even as Congress brace
for confirmation with Nixon overspending
War Powers and other issues its defiance
was tempered by doubts as to whether it
was indeed any match for the newly
reelected president but by the time
Congress adjourned on December 20 1974
the balance of power had shifted
dramatically both Nixon and Agnew had
been driven from office in disgrace
replaced by men whom Congress had a hand
in select and remember there was no
election for Gerald for he was he was
the Minority Leader the Republican
leader in in the house so Congress
really selected the next president
meanwhile last quote meanwhile moving
into a vacuum created by the
disintegration of executive leadership
Congress had staked out a commanding
role for itself and it became one of the
great administrators of the executive
branch the way it organized and
established its control over the
executive branch now that view of Nixon
and the popular understanding of
Watergate as the greatest constitutional
crisis of all time remains unshaken
after more than 40 years I was not
convinced in or now that the crisis
could be understood as purely personal
or strictly legal as I noted before
nearly every presidential administration
has potential scandal that lies just
below the surface of public or political
life they rarely erupt into a full-blown
crisis of the political order the danger
Nixon
to the political establishment after his
reelection was that he promised to use
the power of the executive branch in a
way that threatened to undermine the
power of the newly created
administrative the newly created
centralized administrative apparatus and
thwart its relationship with Congress
the bureaucracy in the courts I thought
at that time that could not that it
could not be Richard Nixon alone who
made it impossible to establish a
consensus on fundamental issues in
American politics rather it was the
person was precisely the inability to
prevent such political disagreement
between the parties and the branches of
government that made Watergate possible
in fact it might have been necessary for
the defenders of the modern
administrative state why did the
political branches and parties diverge
in such a manner as to make it
impossible for them to pursue a common
good in tandem what was at stake was not
merely the prerogative of the branches
or the protection of partisan
differences rather what made consensus
impossible was a disagreement over what
constituted a fundamentally good or just
regime was the modern administrative
state that progressive inner innovation
that took shape in the New Deal and was
greatly expanded in the Great Society
more fundamentally just than the
political structures that have been
established centuries before in the
Constitution itself the existence of
parties indicates that differences of
opinion have existed since the beginning
of the Republic concerning this
constitutionality of specific policies
political quarrels were channeled into
defense of constitutional prerogatives
but the ground of any civil dispute
ation was that the comprehensive
goodness or justice of the Constitution
was beyond dispute what lies at the
heart of the contemporary did they
is that the principle differences
between the parties are no longer
disputes concerning the
constitutionality of politics but a
disagreement concerning the justice of
constitutionalism itself the rationale
polish policies adopted by the
administrative state such as absolute
economic social regulation establishment
of the various security needs all of
those things that establish that us that
are established by the modern
administrative state established the
political and moral justification for
the government itself it denies the
fundamental presupposition of
constitutionalism which is that the
power of government must be limited and
its scope scope confined to the
protection of the political or natural
rights of its citizens the political
essence of the Constitution was not
contained merely in its written language
but in the political structure which
required a separation of powers and the
branches of government
it was the constitutional principle of
separation of powers that had come to be
undermined by the growth of the
administrative state the Great Society
had changed the institutional dynamic of
Washington's politics after the election
of 1964 both political branches and both
participated in establishing greater
political power in Washington by
expanding and centralizing
administrative Authority in the
executive branch bureaucracy that
centralization of administrative
Authority created a political reaction
in the electorate that began the process
of undermining the policies that were
established in the wake of the 1964
election the Republican Party led by
Richard knickers Nixon established
itself as the part is an opponent of
centralized administration although
Nixon's first term required political
concessions that often necessitated the
expansion of federal powers it was done
by more primary
in order to garner support for the
Vietnam War in a congress composed
overwhelmingly overwhelmingly controlled
by the the opposition party now those of
you that are too young although I know
many of you remember what 1968 was like
that was a year of tremendous upheaval
in America riots assassinations we had
500,000 troops in Vietnam when Nixon
took office three to four hundred body
bags were coming back to America every
week and television was showing the war
in Vietnam on the nightly news
so Nixon's preoccupation in that first
term had to be with foreign policy but
Nixon's second term was not a
continuation of the first even the New
York Times noted that that
transformation demanded by Nixon of his
administration after his reelection
was as extreme as if an opposition party
had won the election now some of you may
remember Nixon demanded every executive
in his administration submit their
resignation that included even Henry
Kissinger and the big week because Nixon
was saying he's tired of appointing
people to these offices and then they
become tools of the bureaucracy so after
Nixon's re-election in 1972 he posed a
serious threat to the authority and
power of the bureaucracy and the
administrative state but look at what
happened with the scandal his electoral
victory would not turn out to be the
determining factor that would shape the
political landscape of the future one
that had been legitimized by the people
themselves politics after Nixon was
shaped by his opponents who had merely
to remove Nixon from office and even
without the necessity of impeach this is
why the American the constitutional way
is always preferable he should have been
if he if there was wrong
doing he should have been impeached if
he had been impeached the kind of thing
that Jeff Shepard was talking about last
night could not have happened because
both sides would publicly reveal what
they were doing that didn't happen in
Watergate with this with a special
prosecutor now although the inability to
accommodate the differences between
Nixon his and his opponents involved a
deeper intellectual or theoretical
disagreement as I mentioned before the
difference between a moral acceptance of
the Constitution or its rejection by
those who accept the administrative
state is establishing moral authority so
there was a theoretical or an
intellectual disagreement that laid
below the surface of the political but
it revealed itself as a political
problem during the second Nixon term far
from being personal or a legal problem
it was political to the core as Henry
Kissinger subsequently noted you know
just quote from him Nixon this is a
quote in the final analysis had provoked
a revolution it had he had been
re-elected by a landslide in a night in
1972 in a contest as close to being
fought on ideological issues as it's
possible in America the American people
for once had chosen on philosophic
grounds not on personality for reasons
unrelated to the issues and
unforeseeable by the people who voted
for what Nixon represented this choice
was now being annulled with as yet
unpredictable consequences well we
witnessed the consequences of it's still
a decisive event in how all of politics
was shade after 1974 it was after the
Nixon presidency that the Washington
establishment thought it necessary to
turn to the question of ethics in
politics in 1978 in the wake of
Watergate Congress passed the
ethics and government Act however that
law which created the Independent
Counsel statute was intended to serve a
partisan and not a constitutional
purpose the partisan purpose which it
served quite well was the defense of the
centralized administrative structure put
in place by the Democratic Party
majorities in the 60s and 70s political
control of the executive branch well as
I said before at the same time
strengthening the administrative
authority of the executive branch
it was the legislative majority's way of
dealing with presidents and senior
executive branch officials who might
undermine or threaten the role of
Congress in managing and exercising
control over the sprawling executive
branch administration it sought to
prevent unified presidential control of
the executive branch that could only be
done by making high-level executive
branch officials accountable to
committee and subcommittee chair or the
bureaucracy in the courts although it
was defended on the ground that
executive discretion must be subordinate
to law it's political purpose was to
institutionalize a defense of the
permanent government one that is not
subject to political control
in fact it allows the nonpartisan or
neutral mechanism of the administrative
state the bureaucracy and courts to
establish the permanent government as
the arbiter of the political world we
see this very clearly by the 2016
election where the those in the
bureaucracy and it doesn't matter where
they stand in the bureaucracy have a
proprietary interest over the government
and even determine whether or not
somebody's fit for the office or not so
why is it why had it suddenly become
necessary to establish an independent
prosecutor or special counts
in order to adjudicate the abuses of
presidential authority in utilizing non
political entities the Justice
Department courts and law enforcement
the permanent government created a legal
arbiter of the political process with
significant power as a former prosecutor
has written recently the Department of
Justice is an institution vested with
formidable resources including its
authority over the FBI it is also often
the beneficiary of thinly veiled yet
presumed allegiance with most of the
federal courts in which its attorneys
operate as a result and given enough
time in most cases the Department of
Justice is empowered via favorable
rulings and otherwise to access
manipulate and maneuver the federal laws
rules regulations and procedures not to
mention witness testimony in whatever
way it may deem necessary to ultimately
bring most of those it targets to heal
perhaps even including a president for
nearly a hundred ninety years there was
no legal mechanism that was deliberately
placed outside the political and legal
authority granted by the Constitution to
the political branches themselves that
document had carefully established a
political doctrine it assumed that all
serious disputes would be political in
character and each of the branches would
defend the interests of their respective
institutions they assumed the motives of
all of the participants would involve
self-interest and would consist
therefore of differences of opinion
concerning both the private and public
good in such circumstances when all of
the opinions of all of the participants
are necessarily political the founders
thought it best to rely on human
Aitch to reveal and moderate the motives
of the various office holders the best
way to resolve a political dispute as
James Madison put it is to allow
ambition to counteract ambition in the
most serious cases of disputes between
the political branches the legislature
has the power to impeach the president
in such circumstances the adjudication
of the dispute is in the public arena
and both sides can make their case to
the public consequently it's not the
courts that decide the outcome rather to
establish the lividly that the
legitimacy of government the people must
decide it was meant to be the people
would determine who's right when the two
branches come to odds that can't be
reconciled among the grantors themselves
that's what impeachment was meant to be
by the end of the 20th 20th century it
appeared to be the case that American
politics could no longer be structured
by the ordinary or practical operation
of separation of powers rather the
actual conduct of the political branches
of government was shaped by the ongoing
necessity of accommodating and ratifying
the actions of rational or
administrative bureaucracy in other
words it was an element of government
itself the bureaucracy which had
established the purpose and unity of the
political branches and with the
blessings of the court and Congress in
short after nearly half a century of his
growth the bureaucracy has become the
conservative defender of the liberal or
administrative state once established
the bureaucracy and political forces
beholden to it have sought to
progressively replace politics by
substituting administrative rulemaking
for general lawmaking and rule by
technical or rational law knowledge in
place of political choice choices made
by electoral elected officials
in short political the political rule of
law gives way to executive or
administrative discretion in our time
both political branches of government
and in some ways both parties have
accommodated themselves to the
administrative state much greater
authority resides in the administrative
rail under executive control most often
as I've said with the blessings and
meddling of both Congress and the courts
the growth of the administrative state
has made it possible to politicize the
culture by undermining the institutions
of civil society including the family
church in nearly all private Association
that transformation was not brought
about politically but administrative ly
through the bureaucracy and the courts
whether that transformation would have
been possible political politically if
it had required Congress to pass
legislation that required a majority
consensus is very doubtful without
partisan political consensus it was
almost inevitable those political
divisions would accelerate because they
could never be adjudicated in a manner
combative compatible with Democratic
consent when decided by the bureaucracy
and the courts you could see as Ben
Sasse pointed out in that Cavanagh
hearing the courts now are understood to
be policymakers because Congress refuses
to make laws so
nonetheless let me say the various
national organized interests whether
political economic social media
entertainment educational scientific
cultural or religious we're well
equipped to accommodate themselves to
the centralized administrative rule
moreover they continue to be well served
by Washington in terms of access to the
political branches in the bureaucracy
but it is not clear the American people
are convinced that government now
operates on behalf of a public or common
good for that reason alone the
administrative state has not been able
to establish its legitimacy but the
difficulty of revitalizing political
rule in a manner compatible with
constitutional government remains the
problem yet to be solved and looking
back at Watergate over after 40 years
what did it reveal at the time I thought
it important to look at the
institutional structure and the
incentives of those that had become part
of the modern administrative state I
attempted to show the importance of the
bureaucracy is an institution that could
utilize its influence on behalf of one
political branch or the other the
necessity to preserve those
administrative structures had become
essential to modern government
legitimacy was understood in terms of
the administrative state and not the
Constitution or even the nation itself
it led many within those organizations
to consider institutional loyalty as
fundamental to the defense of democratic
government itself you can notice that
the people who whether it was the FBI
agents are the various people who
thought that they had the moral
authority to defend their institution
they were not even apologetic about what
they were doing they were arrogant in in
the defense of those institutions
and that is because they believe those
institutions establish a government that
is a government that is defensible for
the reasons that the administrative
state is defensible for that reason of
course the nonpartisan character of
bureaucracy its avowed neutrality could
not even any longer be taken for granted
by those in political office the
permanent government had become a
defender of the administrative state a
faction on behalf of government that
could no longer be regulated by
government was many years after
Watergate that we learned the identity
of the sources the source of the leaks
that led to a removal of a president it
was not surprising to me that deep
throat although I certainly didn't know
it at the time
the source for Bob Woodward Carl
Bernstein turned out to be a high-level
direct official of the FBI mark felt had
access to all of the classified
information generated by the agencies of
government he leaked that information
selectively to the Washington Post over
the course of a year or more Woodward
and Bernstein through leaves helped
shape public opinion in ways the
prosecution could not because of their
necessity for secrecy remember even the
defense of Nixon had no knowledge of
what the prosecution was doing so
although Woodward and Bernstein were
lauded as investigative reporters they
serve merely as a conduit by which the
bureaucracy could undermine the
authority of an elected office hold and
as I said if Jeff Shepherd is right in
his revelations concerning the real
Watergate scandal the legal community
including the courts the prosecutors and
even the judges were willing to forego
the procedural requirements that
establish the necessary conditions of
impartiality or fairness they had all
become active partisans in opposition to
Nix so all of the all of the neutral are
supposedly the non partisan branches of
government have participated in in a
sense establishing themselves as
adjuncts of the administrative state and
no longer understand their role
Constitution in modern organizations
those who work in the administrative
structures often understand their
interest in terms of institutional
loyalty and their professional
association rather than the larger
public good understood in terms of the
rule of law the nation or the
Constitution ensure the bureaucracies
have developed the instinct for
self-preservation at all cost
they do not however defend themselves on
the basis of self-interest nor do they
think of themselves as scoundrels by
breaking the law rather they see
themselves as defenders of institutional
rationality a technical rationality
that's established in these nonpartisan
non-political institution as a part of
the social intelligence that establishes
the legitimacy of rule within the
administrative state for many the more
the moral authority of the rational
state has replaced that of the
Constitution and undermined the law and
the rule of law both of which must be
established and defended by political
not
legal authority Theodore white it was a
great Chronicle chronicler of
presidential elections noted in his
attempt to explain the politics that
grew out of the election of 1972 he put
it this way and I quote the Watergate
affair is inexplicable in terms of older
forms of corruption in American history
where men broke laws for private gain or
privilege the men involved were involved
at a moment in 1972 when history was
moving their way they were trying to
speed it up by any means fair or foul by
so doing
perhaps they wrecked their own victory
and then as history may record that in
that as history may record compounds
their personal felonies with national
tragedy now Theodore white knew what we
all knew then it is debatable whether
Nixon had history on his side as his
white assert in in 1972 but there was no
doubt that he had an adversary who
opposed his view of what should be done
in Washington
those adversaries and the political
arena did not attempt to establish their
legitimacy with reference to the
electorate nor had they sought to
utilize the constitutional powers to
oppose to oppose the president rather
they depended upon those institutional
forces of the permanent government
including the bureaucracy the courts and
mass media to undermine Nixon support
within the electorate I don't think it's
possible to separate politics and laws
but it is possible to hold those who
make laws accountable to the people in
establishing the judicial step in
establishing the judicial or the
bureaucracy or whatever of the
nonpartisan of institutions as the
arbiter of the political the guardians
are only accountable to themselves and
those they serve which is typically the
establishment in the public arena
scandal
serves only a political purpose whether
it succeeds or not is dependent upon who
establishes its meaning regardless of
the truth that has been revealed by the
labors of those who have reexamined the
scandals of the past including some of
the speakers you've had I'm afraid they
will have little political impact on the
meaning of those scandals in the end I
would say when the legend becomes fact
they will continue to print the legends
thank you
[Applause]
few questions please raise your hand and
wait for a microphone to be brought to
you
should the FBI be separated from the
Department of Justice I don't I don't
know if it should be separated I think
it it what do you see with the way in
which it's controlled politically in
other words when political appointees or
political partisans establish it's the
control over it it it's it it uses its
the law enforcement function on behalf
of partisan purposes I would say the FBI
perhaps sirs are there there's a role
for the FBI and in national public life
but the CIA which was established just
to accommodate the conditions of the
Cold War should have been disbanded at
the end of the Cold War these two
agencies have great power CIA and FBI
and they seem to cooperate with each
other as well and you notice the only
agency in the recent year in the last
since 2016 that did not go along with
the Washington establishment in the way
in which Trump was treated was Mike
Rogers who's an admiral and was head of
the National Security Agency he's a
military security he's the one that told
Trump that he was being bugged
and that's when Trump moved out of the
Trump tire that this was after he was
elected but before he was inaugurated
just think if Trump had not known this
was happening he would have been in the
in a worse situation than Nixon almost
because he he hadn't even won an
important a big decisive victory so I
don't know what you do I think you know
the FBI and these entities agencies they
certainly have to be better under better
control when these people start leaking
when they start getting perks from the
media and the news organizations as part
of their job they become corrupted as
anything there's any human beings can be
under those circumstances so whether the
FBI is needed I think you probably need
a police force in the in the
during World of even at the national
even at the national level but III think
the FBI was always a force for powerful
partisans I mean J Edgar Hoover was not
an opponent of the country but he was
very careful about how he conducted his
affairs and it wasn't always in line
with the political figure so I don't
know I I don't have a recommendation as
to what could be done with it we have a
question on the speakers left what's
your advice to the Trump legal team to
play the legal game or just force deny
request for interviews interrogatories
and simply say use the Constitution in
the Pietschmann Avenue I will not I will
not participate in these legal
proceedings well you know that would be
it that would be a tactic you could take
if you had partisan support in your own
party which Trump does not seem to have
the leadership of his party behind it
and so it makes it a lot harder for
Trump to ignore those things because
he's not sure he's going to get support
from his own party on these questions
and so if he had if he demands
impeachment will his party support him
in the legislature what you have right
now I think in Washington is you have a
Washington establishment that likes the
way business is done in Washington
that's true of both parties and they
want to preserve the way that business
is done and Trump poses a threat to the
way it's done and so of course there
they're not too happy to you know had he
been a normal normal camp candidate for
the presidency he would they would have
been on board after he won the
nomination and if he had run in 2016
with partisan support of his party
throughout the electorate because he
made it it became very difficult for
members of Congress to oppose to some to
have Trump to embrace Trump when the
National Party wasn't embracing him and
if they had done that in 2016
many of those candidates now would be
much better shape in 2018 the mid term
for Trump would be much better because
normally midterms you lose you lose
seats anyway but Trump is establishing a
new political landscape so it's not
clear what the landscapes going to be
but it certainly would have been easier
like in my state of Nevada when the
Republicans would didn't embrace Trump
in 2016 that election led to the
Democrats winning the offices because it
diffused all of trumps into the
supporters enthusiam they did not want
Republicans in office that would not
even support Trump
public so now in 2018 they're much more
hospitable those candidates in in Nevada
but it's but it's a little late and and
so you're you've now got the opposition
party or gonna mobilize to on behalf of
things that are going to be harder to to
overcome but again III think that's a
very unusual situation to be in because
normally the institutions are organized
by parties and the party that you're a
part of should should support you but
it's not clear that some of the
leadership of the Republican Party is
any less hostile than many of the
Democrat on the speaker's right
thank you I found your talk very
enlightening and a little depressing
since you made that statement that
Admiral Rogers was the only one that
told Trump yeah where is the
uncorruptible man is it in the military
well I I think let's say the military
probably has a better connection to the
country than those who are in the civil
institutions in other words for for
Rogers it's probably you know you look
at these office holders now in
Washington it's not even clear that they
prefer this country to other country I
mean so when you have to when you have
to when you have to re-establish a
ground of the defense of the nation when
the offices that give legitimacy to
these positions are flaunted in the
sense that they don't even care who
elects them once they get the office
then of course that's a much more
difficult problem and that's what you
have with this present state and
particularly I think this becomes a
bigger problem at the end of the Cold
War it would have been impossible for
any national leader during the Cold War
to not defend his own nation and the
offices established by that nation and
given legitimacy by the election the
electorate of that nation when you can't
even distinguish really between who who
who is a legal resident who isn't those
things don't seem to matter too much we
have a question in the back for the
speaker thank you for joining us today
mr. Marini I am a sophomore here at
Hillsdale and like my fellow students we
really only know about Watergate from
the history books and from people like
you sharing about it with us but as we
hear about the Trump administration and
there's always this threat from the
other side about impeachment I can't
help but think about Watergate when you
hear these these threats of impeachment
in the news
does it concern you in the way that
maybe it did when Watergate was
happening do you think it's legitimate
and could actually result in impeachment
or do you think it's just media hype
trying to scare people into thinking
it's a Watergate situation no I think
there's many many similarities because
scandal and and trying to remove one
from office without impeachment is a
much easier way but you know impeachment
means that the people still remain a
major force in politics they would
prefer not to have the people remain a
major force in politic and so that makes
it so yes yeah I think the the whole the
whole necessity that I think there have
been in since the administrative state
was put in place and that happened only
especially after the 1964 election when
Congress reorganized itself and became
really an oversight rather than the
legislative body there have been three
presidents who have understood the
necessity of trying to remake to keep
the connection between the political
offices in the electorate in other words
the government has to be ratified and
legitimized by the consent of the
government that means elections decide
things and of course those three
presidents who have recognized consent
as fundamental were Nixon Reagan and and
it seems to be Trump now and you know
this Trump is a guy who when he when he
went and ran he says when he when he won
on the basis of how he ran he tries to
actually put into effect what he ran on
that's kind of a you know unusual in
modern politics
because they all run the same way in
terms of saying to the organized groups
what they want to hear but the minute
they get office they've forgotten what
what they said because it was
meaningless in the first place so the
the presidents who have accommodated
themselves best to the administrative
state have been all the recent
presidents first Clinton using of course
many ways of being and when Clinton said
the era of big gut
Herman is over he wasn't lying what he
meant was this is now going to be the
ear of big administration the use of
executive power the use of the various
tools of executive power like executive
orders signing statements all kinds of
ways which Bush himself the george h
george w bush did the same thing obama
did the same thing in terms of the use
of executive administrative power and it
seems to me Trump is trying to
re-establish more of an executive
political power and he's demanding that
Congress start doing some things and in
fact remember for the last twenty years
or so
Congress did not even follow its own
regular order it always ended up having
omnibus or reconciliation bills at the
just at the end just before the fiscal
year is required it and in doing that of
course they made decisions only with the
leadership of the committee of the both
parties and the president and the
executive branch leadership you you as
Harry Reid once said there's about it 15
or 18 people in Washington that make the
decisions he was talking it's not wasn't
far wrong but this year
Trump has now had push Congress they've
actually passed I believe seven
appropriations bill they're trying to
get regular order back Trump keeps
telling you should be doing these things
the Congress should be should be passing
laws they should be doing the things
that are net the executive orders are
not a good way of governing because that
can be reversed by the next executive as
as as of course Trump has not been
immune from using it because it was so
abused by the former presidents that
he's starting to use executive orders to
undermine the executive orders that
Obama used but if you want to do it
right you've got to pass laws you've got
to get an agreement you got to get a
consensus and when it it works when the
policies work of course then it's harder
for the pot for the next
party or whoever wins to change things
so you have kind of at the present you
have people who win office campaigning
for office and they keep their their
presidency is is like an ongoing
campaign because nobody's agreed to
anything there's no consensus on
anything in Washington but that's it
that's done by elections what that means
of course is that the consent of the
governed doesn't matter too much to the
wash to them we have time for one more
question thank you very much for coming
this afternoon there were many areas
where you hardly agree with you in many
areas where a heartily disagree with you
which I believe is good for critical
thought yeah sure what I see what I
gained from what you had in your
presentation along with last night now
in my position I'm more from a liberal
bent what the resignation of President
Nixon and what went on after that was a
huge travesty of justice and my wife and
I had quite a animated discussion on it
on the way home last night and we both
came to that conclusion that there were
wrongs that happened but did it come
from a large political group or did this
come from a more focused group with a
judge who needed to make a name for
himself before he retired and then
people he gathered around him everybody
agreeing on the purpose of personal gain
where there was no guidance of any
internal moral compass but each person
within
this group decided they were gonna work
for their own edification and honor how
would you treat that well obviously I
agree that there are many personal
motives that are necessary to to under
to try to understand some event my my
focus then was trying to understand what
the institutional incentives were
because these people most people in
government now work within structures
these structures are already established
and they do business in a certain way
and so those those institutional
structures and those institutional
incentives make it easier to do certain
kinds of things would have been look it
would have been impossible if all you
need it all you had was integrity in
terms of believing that the judicial
system had to function in an impartial
way no matter who was before you if you
make the moral decision that Nixon was
beyond the pale then of course you've
already repudiated or you've denied the
necessity of the rule of law so III
think when I tend to look at these
things I have looked at them from the
point of view of how the incentives of
the way in which modern government is
content is conducted has established
individual incentives which make it do
make that make it possible for those
people to do what you're suggest to
break the laws break the rules it's
easier to break rules too if you don't
believe that that the moral character of
the regime is is justified as well right
if you think the regime is corrupt and
you think that the goal of the regime is
to establish government as it has been
established by the various liberal
presidents of the twentieth century then
of course it's easy
than to to ignore those devices that are
meant to ensure that people who hold
offices cannot use those offices on
behalf of parties on behalf of personal
goals and yet I don't see how you can
separate the self-interest of an
individual and their perception of what
a public good is what the public
interest is and so yeah I as I said
about the American founders they always
assumed that you would be looking out
for your self interest but they also
assumed of course that there would be
debates over what the pomp of the public
good or the common good is so you would
look if Congress is the body that is
meant to deliberate on these policies
that establish the general laws of this
country when pas when Congress refuses
to legislate it essentially says we
don't have a public discourse about what
should be good policy in this country
Congress if Congress refused to do its
job which was to legislate to deliberate
all of the things that the legislative
body does and should do simply to
establish a consensus what do you do
with all those decisions that they don't
make they're made by courts
so is it easier to settle a political
issue by having say five people on the
Supreme Court
make a moral decision about this or that
abortion or any other policy question
that is that is a divisive in the
country those problems never get solved
now if you haven't the possibility of
mobilizing majorities and minorities
come together trying to lobby Washington
and Congress to get laws that are
acceptable to large numbers of people
when you do get that kind of consensus
it's easier than for people to live with
the outcome of laws even if they
disagree with because they've
participated in them what you're talking
about and you're right I think the best
the only people that have an advantage
in in the American system now or
organized interests and that's and
that's I don't just mean II cannot I
mean every interest there's no interest
in this country that doesn't have some
apparatus in Washington that establishes
the viewpoint of that as fundamental to
how it once certain kinds of outcomes in
the policy arena now if you went back
just to 1964 I mean if you went to
Washington in 1964 you would find that
there were no hardly and there were no
economic interest lobbying Washington
because you still had to lobby Albany or
Sacramento because the states controlled
a great deal of the activity that goes
that went on in this country once you
centralize all of that it becomes easier
it becomes easy for the centralized
those people that are able to lobby
Washington to create a universal policy
that that is established everywhere and
went and so it's it's it's a lot easier
for them to be influential in one place
than having to be influenced and trying
to influence politics in 50 states
Nixon's main goal in 1972 if you read
all the speeches leading leading up to
it and if you read his memoirs was how
do we get administrative power out of
Washington that was what he was trying
to do and that's what that's one of the
few things that would make centralized
administrative rule more difficult
because the more centralized it is the
more the more professional it becomes as
well and I mean by that that what
establishes the authority for those
decisions is technical knowledge not
politics now some questions you can
answer with technical or scientific
knowledge but political questions you
can't so it's it's a complex problem
that is posed by
the way in which modern governments
establish their authority through these
rational structures and most kinds of
organizations are happy to use that but
in a political organization you can't
allow the rational we can allow rational
rule to overrule political rule and
still be a free people so that's the
please join me in thanking dr. Rainey